[Musique]
quoi de mieux qu'un bon morceau de sucre
à la crème onctueuse et fondante pour
combler une dent sucrée
malgré ces quelques ingrédients ce n'est
pourtant pas une recette facile à
réussir le ce cas la crème est souvent
trop mou trop granuleux ou trop dur rémy
vous avez cuisiner pour nous ce qu'est
la crème
c'est pas compliqué en principe a dit
que c'est très simple ce qui a créé une
soul ce cas crème ou une sauce boris
cote comme les engrais pour elle
l'appliqué vient du terme
scott chi alors fake c'est vraiment une
sauce faite à base de cassonade qu'on va
manquer comme des provinces une source
raté
moi je pense que la recette
traditionnelle de sucre à la crème est
très simple elle se compose de trois
ingrédients la crème la cassonade et le
sucre le chef pâtissier rémy couture y
ajoute sa touche personnelle
moi j'y arrive avec une twist avec du
sirop d'érable évidemment on est au
québec est un petit peu de sirop de maïs
les ici on a dû foncé on pourrait
prendre du claire aussi
c'est tout simplement un anti
cristallisant on commence avec les
liquides et le sirop de maïs ce qui va
permettre que caen va mettre le sucre
il va automatiquement se diluer dans le
sirop d'érable et là on peut y aller
avec le sucre
si on le laisse partir en brasse pas on
est tenté ouais c'est ça fait que j'ai
mon ce cas la crème à 115 qu'est ce que
je fais en ce moment c'est simplement le
mettre dans un autre contenant pour
arrêter sa cuisson et pour savoir si
votre su khaleq rémy près il suffit de
faire le truc du petit boulet alors pour
faire le petit boulet on va vraiment se
tremper les doigts dans l'eau faut
toujours un petit fine couche d'au
dessus on vient jouer sans ramasser un
petit peu que l'on veuille laisser
refroidir dans l'eau glacée les pilot
ici on va être capable de faire le
fameux petit boulet on peut voir mais
qui va obtenir par s'affaisser sur
elle-même vraiment ce saut il ne reste
qu'à ajouter une noix de beurre et
attendre que la préparation atteignent
55 degrés avant de bras c'est moche à
des tickets on va brasser clos on va
quand même ajouter rapidement on veut
défendre les cristaux puis l'on veut pas
l'effet sablonneux il fallait ce qu'a
créé un club vraiment une texture très
caramel le sucre à la crème québécois
prend différentes formes dans le monde
les écossais ont leurs tablettes l'hymne
irlandais leur bourse plate et les sud
américains eux leurs tables as de lecce
et marnaise de lecce en galets mettre en
cloque du litre de lait on va mettre un
peu de a décompté sous hédé on peut
échanger les colleurs en tête losc à la
mairie c'est et on va mettre aussi
vraiment bonne manille mexicaine
préférence afin de préparer les
macaronis de lecce on doit brasser le
lait et le sucre jusqu'à ce qu'il
s'évapore et forme une pâte filo
cependant combien de temps que ça vaut
cuirasse à cuire pas parce qu'elle en a
marre car mes bras s'est quant à lui la
récré peut-être l'histoire raconte que
ce sont les argentins qui ont créé ces
dulce apparemment ça commençait à
cadenas ajoute m la table les tables de
sucre à la crème mais c'est les gens qui
aimait beaucoup les les cafés tu as le
sirop et qu'elle laisse argentine le
méthane en boîte comme pour avoir une
bonne pendant ton poste ou la journée
tout comme jo
cette la journée comme avec ton caramelo
vous utilisez pas de thermomètre non
fallait faire les souks à la crème elle
a besoin parce que tu aimerais vraiment
au caramel
noam à faire une réduction des délais
avec tel succès c'est la différence
entre les québécoises et les latinos
maintenant il faut comme laisser
évaporer tout et laisser les autres cas
la malice elle doucement mais aussi faut
que je fasse un peu de travail je peux
que je me retrouvais la bouche et aimer
le ciel commence à vraiment changer le
texte se rincer les plus résistants
quand le droit de manger de blaise
anglais après ça sèche pour amar ap
défaut comme les manger quand ses frais
je viens de trouver un concentré penser
aux bonbons à la pâte d'amande la
texture ça pas le même goût ça pas le
goût d'amande et de vanille mais la
texture on est vraiment prêt de l'oim
oui et comme le sucre à la crème de rémy
est enfin prêt et là on va venir faire
des petits cubes pour ma déco de thomas
lorsqu'on a le droit d'y goûter
oui voilà ma chère débreak à mâcher très
longtemps que je prenne un bossu cave a
créé avec un beau petit goût d'érable
c'est vraiment ainsi qu à la craie et
inexact le bouquet ce que vous allez
faire avec selon moi je vous décorer une
bûche une belle bûche qu'on allait en
temps des fêtes
ce cas la crème pommette décorer avec
les sauces ce cas la crème
c'est vraiment très cochon et puis là on
a fait des petites bosses hommes comme
en bout de buch
seul on peut manger sopi mourir après
puisse pas grave c'est ça exactement
2020 sera la grande année pour tout le
monde avec 7 buts chier c'est la coupe
stanley du caramel c'est tellement bon
genre de dessin il ya des émotions ici
comme dirait ma grand mère c'est juste
des bonnes affaires que ça peut pas être
mauvais exact heures
merci rémi moyenne
[Musique]